form and might I throw the bangko at
Banco the anti Benko Burbank oh let's
not let's try something else and what I
have in mind is the Slav and Knight f3
okay I want to try this out I want to
learn more about this so I'm going to
play it all right let's get my bishop to
f5 I waste time I waste time by taking
like this and I give my opponent a
better center but this is a weakness now
that Bishop move interesting hmm if I
play here there is this efore move
should i play my night here let's go
with it and now i think i might want to
throw a question of this dark square
Bishop I don't want ye for to come in
one shot throw a question of this
let's do it and see if that dark square
Bishop has up its sleeve now I'm going
to do this I think yeah if a four is
played now I can back up and if then e 5
i'm in the spot to play g5 in one shot
also one other thing I want to get in is
this move so I could follow up with
Bishop b4 but you know instead of that
I'm going to take into account of
central expansion I think this is still
good even though i'm not making use of
the be four square right away it's at
least stopping some a five maybe night a
for ideas eyeing the c5 be six squares
this move is no longer available needs a
rook or queen support and well now we're
having the lightscribe bishops come off
so let's not waste too much time there
or their castle I guess efore is
available right now and then what
my queen she probably go elsewhere I
think it's pretty good here I don't
really intend on grabbing that pond in
fact taking it loses my Queen to rook on
d to be one Queen a six is on my mind I
think having the Queen's off the board
would benefit me a little bit more or
well i don't know if i should stayed in
that way i think i'll make life easier
for me in this position to get the
Queen's off so let's see what decision
white makes I don't know if it's
objectively best but again i am taking
into account pretty much always the the
current situation we're in that is a
blitz game and trying to make moves that
are going to make my opponent think chew
up their time and now a i could grab
this and they get my bishop should I be
worried about that let's play here not
too afraid of that move I think I might
want to come back here or I might want
to if the position becomes a bit more
simplified I might want to try rook b6 I
i would be there would be some things
i'd have to be cautious about if there's
still a couple nights on the board i'm
throwing my rook on b6 because maybe
there's possibilities that might could
get trapped but now that it's a bit more
simplified i was actually i do that it's
actually illegal don't do that don't you
dare do that let's take bit to my night
i like having my bishop around to
control this be four advance if this
comes in then it could be these white
rooks that can be placing pressure on
the black pawns this night is heading
for a wonderful square a wonderful
square let's do this
and as a follow-up what this night on d3
is fantastic so I'm going to look to get
that bishop and now what more hmm this
night is just fantastic about this this
nights gonna sit right here I keep
pointing it out because it's fantastic
has just these wonderful support points
and it would seem like my bishop playing
here is an important idea if I do this
I'm hitting upon but it's not an
inconvenience the King comes here
defends and his closer to the center
might I want to look into so fixated
this g three Pawn a g3 h5 g4 rook here
to here I can't even go here to attack
the pond cuz that beastly night he's a
beast huh
fishing for a plan here I don't know
that I really have a good one
I just don't know I I just don't know
what do I let's try this I haven't put a
lot of thought into it but I'm going to
give it a shot and i guess some my rooks
just our kind of frozen let's get King
improvement i might want to look into
this or this thinking f2 no I don't know
struggling here this night is just oh I
can't I can't say enough about that
night and now it has made a decision the
decision being I want to get my bishop I
think so and let's pivot here I think my
King has a faster track towards this is
good for me now pretty sure I want to
get at this pond I think I do this King
position very soon need to work on King
position Brooke activity is happening
with this b6 move and now after that I
think there rook is a bit more passive I
just take right away let's do this King
position less than a minute and King
here take and then chase that rook away
and then get my rook active I'm really
just trying to arrive in a position
where I have an active rook versus their
passive rook and now right here is as
active as I could get and I'm not able
to move this smoothly with my pieces
here I don't want to undub their pawns I
think I should run with why not that
move
and maybe this and then c4 I want to get
out that a for pawn I want I want to
keep this rook tied down to the defense
of the pond maybe I could bring my ok
let's I'm going to try for this i'm
going to i have more let me see
something here brooke their up their
pawn push really don't have anything
let's try this again now I could have
done it I could have done it okay I
think now it works because the King goes
there and is in interfering with the
rook they have 20 seconds to figure this
out I wanted to stop there rook from
getting the h1 so that got very timely
right there and now King improvement
king improvement I'm seeing another
thing I want my book on f 2 Broke on f 2
is the plan and my king should probably
go opposite they get out of being
opposite there rook so King to c6 and
then look for an eventual c4 push and
actually I'm going to triangulate first
no no no is this going to be repetition
okay I'm going to do this rook on f2
pawn push next okay i could get a passed
pawn is this going to be fast enough
though oh this is working now this is
definitely working right now you give
check or is it definitely working is it
oh he gets to go back no okay
I'm push pond push to make sure I get
this I almost got in the way there with
my pieces Oh steal me I forgot those
moves were coming with check good game I
thought they were coming with check I
forgot oops it happens oh good game that
was an interesting end game 2 all right
let's flip that board for a second I
thought it said drawn because I was down
on time but I wasn't down on time I just
I played poorly with those last post
that sneaky king at sneaky benko all
right let's go back here what's the
scoop this is a slob defense the Dutch
the Dutch I labeled it recently because
I played it against uh pot sir and post
it to youtube and when I looked it up to
make sure of the particular variation I
think they called it the Queens gambit
declined slav Dutch and it involves this
when you're seeing that a4 move in
response to D takes and then you're
seeing a 4 and then actually i don't
know i know it's at least we could say
it's uh it's going to be a Slav but I
guess I can't be more specific right now
but interesting game I think it's pretty
equal here I don't know okay Queens
coming off maybe Queen back and then you
could get an e4 or something but then
hit being on c2 eventually a night b4 so
maybe it's quite alright that the
Queen's are off if a trade and I like
this a real lot I really like the night
maneuver I think it's really good you
know come to think of it and ok yes I my
opponent saying it's kind of a Moscow
variation if we would have taken on f6
with the bishop okay let's see I guess
there's you know I guess there's another
route to the d3 square I guess we can
also just in um I see myself doing this
a real lot like I'm thinking in Reverse
when it comes to maneuvering to
particular square like i'll be thinking
nike 12 d 31 really ok there's 95 here
really isn't going to make too much of a
difference wow I I don't think it would
make too much of a difference I have the
bishop versus night but I don't know and
here's another thing the current
position of the night versus my bishop
ah I have to kind of just wait around
and watch over that see 5 square so this
is a move that I was in some sense just
kind of happy to see because I I knew ok
I could get rid of that pesky night but
if he's if he doesn't commit just yet
I'm just I'm having to watch out for see
5v5 maybe in other words it's better to
keep me guessing about the Knights
position maybe you'll go here maybe
you'll go here don't don't show your
hand just yet I think your night is more
annoying than my bishop maybe that's a
quick summary in this rook endgame I'm
just looking to get my rook versus a
passive rook so I've established that
and I don't know if I really should have
been able to get that advantage I was
trying to be clever with my timing with
rook be one excuse me rip be a 2 h8 but
yeah like right right now I think rook
back and as soon as the king went here
because if I try to move sooner for
example right now
oh well where was that first instance
where I could have played 2 h8 right
here I went back the king went here now
if I come over to this square the rook
plays to see one it's no longer need you
to defend at be three if i push on h4
there's rook to h1 and in order to save
upon after play to h3 and I wasn't so
sure about that maybe it would have been
okay but I was trying to be sneaky with
getting to this position again with the
King being at sea too so that when I'd
come over here there is an opportunity
to get to the rook to get that white
rook to h1 in time so I get active and
well this is I think this turns out to
be winning although what about takes
takes takes King here then I do this
takes takes King takes here I'd actually
end up now I wouldn't end up queening
maybe you could get away with taking the
rook somebody run the calculation on
this real quick let me know if I'm right
on it if Rick takes rook here who stands
better I think it might be white I think
this is a bad decision by me to play off
to Rick f2 takes takes King e-2c for
takes takes King takes f 2 C 3 kingi to
you're there in time interesting I think
that's a least at least a draw for white
although wait a second this is this is
getting to be a really interesting a
kicking upon in Game having to do some
visual calculations here so run with
this let's see if rook takes pawn takes
I think it's actually winning for black
because of this one pawn on f5
restricting both an e for Angie
or advanced and man rook takes pawn
takes King e-2c for King rc4 pawn takes
pawn takes King takes f king c5
eventually gets to a point where black
in stalemate the White King on c1 and
then one of the white pawns needs to
push and I could just capture and then
run down with the Queen giving me does
anybody else able to follow that I think
that's how it would run if rook takes
rook we're played only because this pond
right here is clamping down on both an
e4 and g4 push I would have been an
interesting end game and I guess that
said it was important for black to not
be taking my rook but maybe instead of
rook e to rookie to maybe rook to see
two is better to watch out for this pawn
push of course I could I guess I could
still wait around a little bit and play
King here and then push so that was it's
got to be a bit uncomfortable having
this connection point on f2 but
interesting interesting game yeah see
this is a similar situation but if you
could I yeah this is a similar situation
if you could imagine this position right
here where even if I didn't have this g3
pond I think it's still winning even
though I'm down upon and this king could
be stopping my pond from going I think
it's still win anyhow very good game
very interesting end game as well right
there that rook and pawn in game very
nice